Hello,
I'm busy getting animated about language
and this is why you should join me.
We've been digging into the decipherment
of ancient scripts in some languages
out there. People sing when they
speak. So how does that work?
It's the U S is 50th state and one
of the most popular tropical vacation
destinations in the world.
But how do you say it's name?
Did you know that bees are out there
talking to each other right now?
Storytellers of old knew how to spin
tales with monsters and ghosts like in
Homer's odyssey,
spirit possession and lady Murasaki's
tale of Genji or even spooky settings as
dog days in Ferno, ancient Sanskrit.
Turn that dial 1000 years into the future.
What will future English be like.